tenemos aquí una tabla que nos dice qué
valores toman las funciones f y g cuando
le damos ciertas entradas por ejemplo
cuando la entrada es menos 4 la función
f toma un valor de 29 porque si x es
igual a menos 4 f de x es igual a 29 así
es que tenemos aquí estas tablas de
entradas y salidas de f y de g y lo que
quiero hacer aquí es evaluar a dos
funciones compuestas distintas porque
quiero que evaluemos a la función
compuesta f deje de 0 y también quiero
evaluar a la función g de f de 0 y como
siempre ponle una pausa del vídeo e
intenta resolverlo por tu cuenta
bueno pues vamos a empezar pensando en f
deje de 0
efe deje de 0 y esto que tenemos aquí lo
que significa es que vamos a evaluar ag
en 0 así es que vamos a tomar la entrada
y vamos a evaluar a la función g en esa
entrada y eso evaluar a g en la entrada
a 0 nos va a dar un valor de salida pero
cualquiera que sea ese valor lo podemos
escribir como g de 0 y luego nos haya
quedado lo que nos haya quedado va a ser
la entrada de la función
efe lo que íbamos a evaluar a efe en
esta entrada y nos va a dar un valor de
salida y sea lo que sea este valor que
nos dé se llama f deje de 0
efe deje de 0 porque allí los escribimos
por aquí debajo de las flechas para
tener espacio para poner los verdaderos
valores y si te sientes inspirado en
estos momentos pone pausa al vídeo y
calcula lo pero en fin
cuánto vale que de cero bueno pues
cuando la entrada es cero cuando x es
igual a cero la función g toma el valor
5 de acuerdo a esta tabla
así es que g
de 0-5 ok esto de aquí es 5 la entrada
que le vamos a dar a la función f 5 lo
que vamos a evaluar a efe en 5 y cuando
la entrada x es igual a 5 la función efe
toma un valor de 11 nuclear
efe de 5 es igual a 11 esto de aquí es
igual a 11 y f deje de 0 es igual a 11
bueno y ahora vamos a evaluar g de f de
0 a g de f de 0 y el truco aquí es
primero evaluar lo que está adentro del
paréntesis y después ya podemos evaluar
a lo que está afuera del paréntesis
así es que empezamos a dentro del
paréntesis queremos encontrar el valor
de la función
efe evaluada en la entrada a 0 así es
que lo primero que tenemos es la entrada
0 y evaluamos a la función
efe
en la entrada a cero y luego nos quede
lo que nos quede en la salida de f
evaluada en la entrada 0 sea eso lo que
nos quede va a ser la entrada que le
vamos a dar a la función g y la salida
de eso va a hacer que de f de cero
porque jgep gf de cero
así es que veamos cuánto vale esto
aunque empezamos por aquí cuánto vale
efe de cero
bueno pues cuando la entrada es igual a
cero esta tabla de aquí nos dice que f
de cero es igual a 1 ok
efe de 0 es igual a 1 efe
de cero es igual a 1 y entonces ahora
usamos 1 como la entrada que le vamos a
dar a la función jefe ahora estamos
evaluando a g
en uno y esto de aquí lo puedo
reescribir como g de uno y lo repito
otra vez porque podemos hacer esto
porque efe de cero es igual a uno y
entonces regresamos a la tabla
cuánto vale g de uno cuando evaluamos a
g en la entrada 1 lo que nos queda es 8
así es que quede uno es igual a 8 gray 8
esto de aquí es igual a 8 y listo ya
terminamos hoy estos de aquí son valores
diferentes porque estas de aquí son
funciones diferentes
efe deje de 0 es 11 y gdf de cero es 8